evidence of a failed bombing mission Sky
News has obtained this photograph that a
security source says is of the suspected
suicide bomber who studied in Britain
Abdul Latif Jameel Mohammad pictured
with a rucksack thought to contain
explosives and a suitcase at the Taj
Hotel in Colombo seven other bombers
exploded themselves in a coordinated
strike on Easter Sunday against churches
and hotels only he didn't blowing
himself up hours later at this low-grade
guesthouse officials say something went
wrong with the charge so he left the Taj
frustrated this footage is said by
locals to be of Abdul walking outside
the tropical Inn in a change of clothes
a receptionist checked him in at around
9:30 just after the mass bombings he
asked for a room with a lock before
dumping his bags and leaving sources say
he visited a local mosque pictured here
in a white shirt four hours later
returning to die
it must be like a nightmare the second
time he came inside he was laughing he
smiled a receptionist so he seemed
relaxed yes he went to the room and the
receptionist totally locked the door
around 8 minutes later came to blast the
blast killed a man and woman in a room
next door reducing this one-story
building to rubble Abdul here in an ID
photo was already under police
monitoring he has two passports and
travelled widely possibly even spending
time in Syria Sky News has obtained
exclusive details of some of his foreign
travel when he may have been radicalized
the suspect made his first known trip to
the UK on the 1st of January 2006 to
study aeronautical engineering at
Kingston University returning to Sri
Lanka via the Maldives in September the
following year he went back to Britain
in 2008 security officials are looking
into his movements and any extremist
links over the next four years he jumped
between Malaysia Singapore and Sri Lanka
Islamic state is known to have a
presence in Malaysia when and how he
became radicalized is under
investigation as is why he chose to
bring terror to this obscure Street on
the outskirts of Colombo
Labour's in the house next door still in
shock then after the big noise feed that
all the the roof and glass all turn to
my head and I've cut myself cross right
so after that I I hold my head and shout
take the baby and take go and go out I
call mama take the baby and go out
because it's a huge noise tensions
remain high police hunt for clues in the
rubble while this family works to mend
their broken home
Deborah Haynes Sky News Colombo